All right, so I joked that this would happen
last week on Twitter.
Uh, and it's happening.
Donald Trump now has said that he does not
know if Rudy Giuliani is his lawyer.
Of course, Rudy Giuliani.
Now under criminal federal investigation,
two of Rudy Giuliani's associates have been
arrested trying to leave the country on one
way playing tickets.
I tweeted last week after Olivia newts, he
wrote that Trump says he hasn't spoken to
Rudy, but Rudy tells me he spoke to Trump
yesterday.
Trump says he doesn't know if Rudy is his
attorney.
Rudy tells me he is and he has no reason to
think he's not.
I tweeted Rudy, who is coming in three, two,
one now we're not yet at Donald Trump saying
Rudy Giuliani.
Yeah, I don't really know who that is, but
we are at Rudy, my attorney.
Oh, I don't know about that.
Here's video Donald Trump asked, is Rudy Giuliani
your lawyer check out Donald Trump's answer?
Well, I dunno, I haven't spoken to Rudy.
I spoke to him yesterday briefly.
Uh, he's a very good attorney and he has been
my
attorney.
I haven't spoken to him.
I spoke to him yesterday.
Well, so you have spoken to him, I guess you
mean you haven't spoken to him in the last
few hours, but you spoke to him yesterday.
He's a good attorney.
I don't know if he's, my attorney.
Rudy Giuliani was asked, are you still Donald
Trump's attorney?
And he said that he is, at least at the most
recent time, I am still his lawyer until he
tells me I'm not.
I spoke to him yesterday and I have no reason
to believe I'm not, he said to New York magazines,
Olivia Newt, see, uh, Rudy was also asked
whether he thinks Trump is going to throw
him under the bus.
And he said he doesn't think so, which does
not.
It's like when Trump says he has full confidence
in you and 24 hours later you've been forced
to resign.
This is exactly what Trump did when Michael
Cohen, who's now in prison, uh, when Michael
Cohen, his, uh, former personal attorney was
starting to get into trouble.
Michael Cohen.
Oh, I don't know.
He was my attorney at one point.
He's not the best guy.
And you know, he was asking me for all this
stuff that I didn't give him Trump after that
video though, that I played, did tweet nice
things about Rudy.
But this is the start of the distancing from
Rudy Giuliani.
We've seen it done before and Trump is doing
it again.
Coffee boy, Rudy Giuliani, he was barely involved
with anything I did.
When you start ghosting your lawyer, you're
prominent, famous on TV everyday lawyer because
he's under criminal investigation and two
of his associates have been arrested and charged.
That's not good, and there's an important
thing to understand here, and this may become
relevant actually, depending on where impeachment
goes, depending on where the criminal investigation
into Rudy Giuliani goes.
What's important to understand is that as
his personal attorney, it's not clear that
Rudy Giuliani is doing legal work per se for
Trump in the sense that Rudy is a lawyer and
calling him Trump's lawyer is useful for attorney
client privilege, but in the strictest sense,
other lawyers are doing Trump's actual legal
work.
The filings and the work you would typically
associate with an attorney.
Rudy Giuliani is basically doing influence
pedaling meetings all over the world and television
appearances, but the bulk of the legal work
is not being done by regionally.
Rudy, Rudy Giuliani, if any at all.
It's becoming a bad comedy.
Does anybody believe that someone in Donald
Trump's position possibly facing charges of
all kinds facing impeachment, doesn't know
who his lawyer is.
That doesn't seem like something that, uh,
is very reasonable even considering that this
is Donald Trump bizarre times that we are
living in.
And who knows if a week from now a Rudy Giuliani
will be under indictment.
It's anyone's guess.
This may be the last we hear of the Rudy investigation
or the guy may be indicted next week.
Either would be equally surprising or unsurprising
to me at this point in time.
Let me know what you think Rudy's future
is legally.